لم تكن مجرد عمليه انتخابيه تلك التي دفعت
به يحيى السنوار على راس مكتب حركه حماس
في قطاع غزه خلفا لاسماعيل هنيه ف السنوار
الاسير المحرر والقيادي البارز في الجناح
العسكري للحركه بمساره
ومواقفه يبدو واجهه جديده لمرحله مختلفه
محاطه بالتحديات فلسطينيا واقليميا ودوليا
وفيما ينتظر ان تستكمل حماس انتخاباتها في
الضفه الغربيه وخارج فلسطين قبل انتخاب
رئيس لمكتب السياسي تتجه الانظار الى
مستقبل التعاطي مع ملفات فائقه الاهميه
ابرزها تهديدات الاسرائيليه والمصالحه
الفلسطينيه والاسرى والعلاقه مع
مصر لطالما ترددت اسرائيل في الافراج عنه
كانت تدرك ان شخصا بحجم يحيى السنوار لن
يكون كاي اسير محرر اخر وان قضاءه اكثر من
20 عاما في سجونها لن يغير شيئا من قناعات
الرجل الذي حمل السلاح في وجهها ووجه
عملائها منذ منتصف ثمانينيات القرن الماضي
وها هو اليوم وبعد سنوات قليله من خروجه
في صفقه شاليط يصبح قائد حماس الجديد في
قطاع غزه الله اكبر يا قطاع غزه بعد
انتخابه من قبل الاف من كوادر الحركه
رئيسا لمكتبها السياسي في القطاع خلفا
لاسماعيل هنيه الذي يستعد بدوره لخوض
انتخابات المكتب السياسي للحركه لخلافه
رئيسه الحالي خالد مشعل ويعد السنوار
المولود في مخيم خان يونس عام 62 مؤسس
الجهاز الامني في حماس المعروف باسم مجد
والذي نشط خلال الانتفاضه الاولى كما انه
احد قلائل ساهموا وبشكل رئيسي في تاسيس
الجناح العسكري للحركه الذي اصبح يعرف
لاحقا باسم كتائب عز الدين القسام كما قد
السنوار ولسنوات طويله الحركه داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه بعد سره عام 88 والحكم عليه
بالسجن اربع مؤبدات وبعد تحرره اصبح
السنوار عضوا في المكتب السياسي لحماس
وتقلد مناصب امنيه وعسكريه حساسه وتقول
اسرائيل انه بات الاقرب الى قائد كتائب
القسام محمد الضيف بحكم الصداقه القديمه
التي تربطهما حيث انهما ابنا مخيم واحد
ويقول مقربون من الحركه ان انتخاب السنوار
على راس المكتب السياسي رغم تاريخه
العسكري والامني الطويل
يدل على رغبه تيار واسع من حماس في دفع
شخصيات صلبه وتشدده الى الواجهه لا سما في
ظل حاله الاحباط التي تسود القطاع من
استمرار الحصار الخانق وتعثر عمليات اعاده
الاعمار ناهيك عن التهديدات الاسرائيليه
بشن حرب جديده على القطاع فالحل برايهم هو
بالتمت اكثر خلف المقاومه كما انه يمكن
قراءته في سياق قطع الطريق على اي محاوله
اسرائيليه مباشره او عبر وسطاء لانتزاع
صفقه تبادل اسرى جديده مقابل ثمن بخس في
حين يرى اخرون ان انتخاب السنوار ربما
يعقد المشهد امام حماس وقد يجرها الى
مواجهه ليست في صالحها او في صالح القطاع
المنهك فضلا عن تقليل فرصها في احداث
اختراق حقيقي في ملفات الحصار على غزه
والمصالحه الوطنيه وكذلك في فرص نسج
علاقات متينه مع اطراف عربيه واقليميه
ودوليه ينضم الينا من غزه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ابراهيم المدهون ومن رام الله
الدكتور نشاه الاقطش استاذ الاعلام
والعلاقات العامه في جامعه بيرزيت نبدا
اولا مع الاستاذ المدهون استاذ مدهون ما
هي دلالات هذا الانتخاب من قبل مؤسسات
حركه حماس في ضوء الخلفيه الامنيه
والعسكريه ل يحيى السنوار ليكون على راس
المكتب السياسي في غزه
اعتقد ان انتخاب السيد يحيى السنوار
لرئاسه حماس في قطاع غزه ياتي في السياق
الطبيعي حيث انه احد رموز الحركه ايضا احد
المؤسسي ومؤسسي قطاعات مهمه مثل الكتله
الاسلاميه ولديه تجربه تجربه سابقه ان
كانت في القياده او حتى في الخبرات
الميدانيه واعتقد انه شخصيه براغماتيه
منفتح قادر على لملمه الملف المفات الهامه
التي تتم او التي تشرف عليها حركه حماس
ولديه قبول ان كان في قواعد الحركه او في
قيادتها وهو قادر على نسج استراتيجيات
وايضا هو شارك في هذه الاستراتيجيات
واعتقد ان هناك تضخيم لخلفيه السيد
السنوار العسكريه وهو ابن لهذه الحركه
التي تعتبر حركه تحرر ومن الطبيعي ان
يشارك ابنائها وقيادتها جميعا في العمل
المقاوم والتي لا تخفي حركه حماس والخلط
بين المقاوم
والسياسي اعتقد انه ليس دقيقا لدى هذه
الحركه التي خاضت الحروب وما زالت ترفع
السلاح وتتبنى الكفاح المسلح ولكن اعتقد
ان شخصيه السنوار هذه ربما تكون اضافه
نوعيه خصوصا انها كانت في بعيده عن
الاعلام وان الاعلام لديه صوره ضبابيه في
حال تكشفت وظهرت الى الاعلام بشكل اكثر
وهذا ما اتوقعه في الايام القادمه ب حسب
موقعه الجديد ان يكون هناك شخصيه مختلفه
عن الصوره الذهنيه التي ارتبطت به طيب واض
واضح جدا دكتور الاقطش يعني ضيفنا في في
غزه يقول عن السنوار بانه شخصيه براغماتيه
و ليس هناك من داع للتضخيم
عمليه انتخابه ما هي برايك الرساله التي
يعطيها تصعيد شخص
بملامح السنوار كواجهه لحركه حماس خاصه
وان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وضعه على قائمه
المطلوبين للتصفيه في قطاع
غزه
صحيح اولا هو اول عسكري يتقلد منصب سياسي
رئيس لحركه حماس في غزه ثانيا وجوده لن
يغير شيء هو كان يحكم غزه بعد تحريره وله
نفوذ واسع في قطاع غزه والان ازداد نفوذه
الرساله ان العسكر يحكمون غزه اصبحت واضحه
كانت ضمنيه في الماضي اي المعلومه المهمه
وجوده لن يؤثر في شيء لانه هو لا يحكم
كفرد والمكتب السياسي المنتخب العسكر هم
في قله هناك قيادات سياسيه هي موجوده في
في هذا المكتب وبالتالي لن يكون هو صاحب
القرار النهائي رغم قوته وصلابته
ومكانته الذي كان يسمى ملك غزه قبل هذا
الانتخاب لذلك اعتقد انه
اي رساله مهمه
اي ان الشعب في غزه يميل او حماس في غزه
تميل نحو الجناح
العسكري رساله للاسرائيليين الذين يحضرون
لحرب قادمه واصبحت الامور واضحه ان
اسرائيل تريد حرب جديده او عدوان جديد على
قطاع غزه قد يكون خلال الشهور القادمه
وجود السنوار هذا يعني ان
الحركه لازالت تتمسك بخيارات
المقاومه المفاجاه انه ما ذكره صديقنا من
غزه ان يكون للسنوار دور في انفاذ المشروع
الاسرائيلي وهو دوله في غزه الى اي مدى
يستطيع ان يؤثر على القياده في القسام
لتقبل العرض الاسرائيلي وهو دوله في غزه
مقابل التنازل او نسيان الضفه الغربيه
معالم المشروع الاسرائيلي اصبحت واضحه
تهويد القدس منع الاذان هي خطوه واحده قبل
اعلان الحل النهائي وهو ضم الضفه الغربيه
وهو ما يلمح اليه يوميا وبالتالي ملامح
الصوره اسرائيل غير معنيه باسقاط حماس هي
وجودها يعزز الانقسام ووجودها يعطي رساله
لاسرائيل في العالم وبالتالي العدوان
القادم لا احد يستطيع ان يتنبا كيف سيكون
هل ستكون حرب مجرد وسيله للسياسيين لتحقيق
اهداف ام ستكون حرب طاحنه ما هو دكتور
اقطش عفوا عفوا لو سمحت لي يعني لا نريد
ان ندخل في كثير من القضايا ربما نتطرق
اليها لاحقا ولكن يعني في واقع الامر انت
كثير مما ذكرت قد يكون في سياق تك هنات
استاذ مدهون لو سمحت لي اتحول الاستاذ
مدهون كيف برايك يعني ينعكس تولي
السنوار زعامه حماس في غزه ويعرف عنه وهذه
حقيقه توجهه خلفيته العسكريه كيف سينعكس
هذا على الحركه ذاتها على عمل المؤسسات
داخل غزه في ظل هناك نوع من الاحباطات
تتعلق بالحصار في التضييقات في وانعكاس
ذلك على الوضع الداخلي في القطاع بغض
النظر عما تفضل وذكره الدكتور الاقطش من
ربما نوايا
اسرائيليه ويجب ان التوقف قليلا عند ما
قاله الزميل من رام الله خصوصا انه يقذف
في وجه هذه القياده الجديده المنتخبه حركه
حماس التي قدمت نموذج يجب الشعب الفلسطيني
او اعتقد ان الشعب الفلسطيني سيفتخر به
كثيرا ان هناك انتخابات نزيهه انتخابات
دوريه ت تمارس بشكل واضح وتفرز دائما
قيادات جديده هذا حقيقه نموذج جديد اما ان
نقذف فزاعه غزه والانفصال اعتقد ان السيد
يحيى السنوار سيكون من اولوياته ترتيب
البيت الفلسطيني وهو يدعم دائما المصالحه
الفلسطينيه وكان له دور بارز في اتفاق
الشاطئ ودعم هذا الاتفاق بشكل كبير واخر
من يمكن ان يتهم انه يتساوق مع الافكار
الاسرائيليه الشيطانيه هو ايه شخصيه مثل
يحيى السنوار الذي يدرك المنطق الاسرائيلي
مثقف جدا قارئ يعرف اللغه العبريه بشكل
طلق قادر على فهم النفسيه الاسرائيليه رجل
استراتيجي حاد ممكن ان يكون قادر على
مواجهه هذه المخططات ان كانت السياسيه
الخبيثه او الملتويه او العسكريه الصداميه
ولهذا باعتقادي اننا نحن امام اي
تجربه فلسطينيه يمكن توقف عندها كثيرا نحن
امام شخصيه يمكن ان يكون لها دور ولكن
الان من المفروض ان تستثمر السلطه
الفلسطينيه شخصيه مثل شخصيه السيد السنوار
ووجود السيد اسماعيل هنيه وخالد مشعل هذه
الشخصيات القادره على ترتيب البيت
الفلسطيني والاتجاه فورا لمواجهه المخططات
الاسرائيليه لترتيب البيت الفلسطيني
واعاده تنظيم منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
واشراك حركه حماس هذه الحركه الفتيه
القويه التي بدا يحسب لها الكثير من
الحسابات والذي باعتقادي انها قادره على
اكمال الدور التي تلعب به السلطه الفلينيه
اخذ من كلامك الاخير واوجه سؤال لو سمحت
لي للدكتور الاقطش يعني ايه انعكاسات يعني
اعاده ترتيب البيت في غزه ستكون على
العلاقه مع حركه فتح وكذلك على المصالحه
الفلسطينيه واي تصور لحلول مثل حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه هل هذا ممكن
هذا غير ممكن شخصيه عسكريه زي السنوار لا
اعتقد انه
سيكون يقدم تنازلات لحركه فتح وحركه فتح
لن تمد طوق النجاه لحصار الغزه لكي تعزز
موقفها وبالتالي اعتقد لا شيء سيتغير في
غزه غزه تعاني منذ ع سنوات وهذه فتره
طويله دول عظمى انهارت بسبب حصار لمده 10
سنوات مثل العراق مثلا وبالتالي يعني يجب
ان لا نتفاءل كثيرا البيت الفلسطيني لا
يمكن ترتيبه البيت الفلسطيني غير قابل
للترتيب على الاصح لانه هناك تقارب
فتحاوي اسرائيلي وحم سوي اسرائيلي نستطيع
الجزم انه اكثر من تقارب حماس وفتح كل
المصالحات من الشاطئ وبعد الشاطئ وقبل
الشاطئ هي شعارات طرحت ولكن عند التطبيق
لا يمكن للناس المتنفذين سواء في رام الله
ان يمدوا خط حبل النجاه لحماس لكي تخرج من
هذا الحصار وحماس لن تتنازل عن غزه لكي
تاتي فتح وتحكمها مره ثانيه والمصالحه هي
بهذا الاطار هي غير قابله للتحقيق ما دامت
موازين القوى الحاليه مصر لا تريد ان ترى
حماس في الوجود اسرائيل لا غير معنيه
بتغيير حماس لانها تريد ان تبتلع الضفه
الغربيه وب وباختصار وجود حماس في غزه
يشجعها الوضع سيبقى كما هو حصار الانظمه
العربيه اليوم تتقارب الى امريكا من خلال
اسرائيل وبالتالي نتائج الاجتماع بين
نتنياهو وترامب بناء عليه سيتقرر مصير غزه
هل هي ذاهبه الى حرب ام بقاء الوضع على ما
هو عليه طيب استاذ استاذ المدهون ايه
ملامح ل واثار متوقعه لهذا التغيير على
العلاقات العربيه الاقليميه
برايه اعتقد ان السيد السنوار معني كقيادي
حركه حماس وكا اخوانه ولانه كان جزء اصلا
اساسي في قياده حركه حماس بتعزيز العلاقه
بترتيب البيت بترتيب العلاقه الاقليميه
وتعميقها خصوصا مع القوى الرئيسيه في
المنطقه
والمحتكر مباشر مع الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى
راسهم اولويته اي مصر و اعتقد ان له دور
كبير في الانفتاح الاخير على اي على على
جمهوريه مصر العربيه ويبدو ان السيد
السنوار سيهتم ايضا في ايضا جلب الدعم
وتعزيز التحالف مع عمقه العربي والاسلامي
بشكل عام ولهذا باعتقادي ان شخصيه تضاف
الى مركزيه حركه حماس بالاضافه الى هنيه
ومشعل هذا سيعطي قوه للحاله الوطنيه بشكل
عام لحركه حماس بشكل خاص ايضا سيعطي افاق
للعلاقه مع الدول الخليجيه والعربيه
والاسلاميه وايضا سيعطي فرصه امام السلطه
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ان ترتب البيت
الفلسطيني وانا اي اختلف مع الزميل في رم
الله بانه هذه لا يوجد افق للمصالحه
بالعكس هناك افاق هناك يمكن تعزيز هذه
الاتفاقيه خصوصا ان هناك شخصيات قياديه
وازنه في حركه حماس الان قادر على اتخ خذت
قرارات هذه القرارات كبيره ولكن تحتاج
ايضا يد من رام الله يد من السلطه
الفلسطينيه خصوصا في ترتيب البيت
الفلسطيني وترتيب منظمه الت ل الش الفلين
لو سمحت لي سيد مدهون سؤال اخير لل
الدكتور الاقطش يعني اذا كانت هناك
انتخابات قادمه الان للمكتب السياسي ويرجح
فوز اسماعيل هنيه بها يعني ما الذي ما
الذي يضير مثلا ان يكون شخصيه عسكريه بهذا
المنصب ب في المكتب السياسي في حركه حماس
في غزه وهناك من هو رئيس المكتب السياسي
بشكل عام لحركه المقاومه الاسلاميه
حماس هو لا يضير هو يؤكد هيمنت القسام على
غزه التي كانت تسيطر ايضا قبل وجود
السنوار في المكتب السياسي وبالتالي هو
نتيجه طبيعيه ان غزه تعيش ظروف قاسيه جدا
فوق التخيل وفوق الاحتمال
وغزه قريبه من الانفجار بتقديرات لانه هذا
هذا طويل يعني قبضه عسكريه في غزه سوف
تتعزز هذا هو الخيار المتاح امام
الفلسطينيين المدهون يقول انه هناك ترتيب
للبيت الفلسطيني علينا علينا ان نواجه
الحقيقه نحن لا نقوم بفعل نحن نقوم بردود
افعال على الفعل الاسرائيلي منذ الاحتلال
وحتى اليوم كل ما نقوم به هو ردود افعال
واعتقد ان غزه الفتره القادمه قد تعاني قد
تستمر في شكرا لك دكتور نشاه الاقطش استاذ
الاعلام والعلاقات العامه في جامعه بيرزيت
كذلك شكرا للكاتب والمحلل السياسي ابراهيم
المدهون متحدثا الينا من غزه الى الملف
الثاني في الحصاد وفيه يستطلع عبد الصمد
ناصر مسار التطورات المتلاحقه في درعا بعد
اشتعال المعارك بين فصائل معارضه وقوات
النظام السوري لمنعه من استعاده معبر درع
الحدودي مع الاردن